sirens blared and the loud ringing of
the emergency alarm system gave everyone
a scare like something had jumped out at
them unexpectedly with that fright came
a sharp jolt of adrenaline something
wasn't right and their options were
either to await instructions or try and
flee with their lives most took the
latter dropping their shovels and
various mining tools so they could turn
heal and bolt to the nearest opening
outside if they could just get outside
above ground where the air was a little
clearer than they could avoid whatever
it was that was happening but for Yuri
Escape wasn't an option he had to do
something it had been a standard
operation everything had been run by the
books and was going all the smoother for
it but that Noble approach hadn't
stopped the drill from breaching into a
cavern carving through Stone into a
previously undiscovered area that on its
own wasn't enough to cause concern it
was the sudden cave-in that had
triggered the alarms and mud to the
ensuing panic at the controls of the
gigantic excavation machine Yuri
helplessly pulled at levers and press
buttons desperately trying to undo the
rapidly worsening damage but it was too
late rocks and debris were showering
from above like the Earth itself was
retaliating against the mining workers
it was as if they shouldn't have drilled
that deep the cave in almost like they
had awakened something unfortunately for
Yuri a falling slab of stone made sure
he wouldn't get to see exactly what the
dust settled shortly after but only one
recorded casualty along with multiple
injured Mine Workers wasn't enough to
deter them from exploring what they had
accidentally stumbled upon venturing
into the cavern system pierced by the
drill those who first dared to set foot
down there were greeted by the sight of
strange crudely built stone structures
someone had been here before but how
nothing could survive this far below
ground nothing living nothing human at
least and that was true given that the
workers also came across something else
in their initial exploration human
remains of course this raised quite a
concern prompting the workers to try and
contact their superiors uncovering
bodies wasn't exactly uncommon for
anyone whose job it was to dig into the
ground so they at least had a protocol
in place for this kind of situation but
none of them were prepared for however
was the fiery Abomination that suddenly
emerged as they were trying to call for
help the creature was a nightmarish
blend of a humanoid shape with the head
of a dog and giant Wings much like a
bats covered in rough fur its body was
exuding an oily flammable substance
which it used to incinerate the
surviving Mine Workers in an instant by
the time that operatives of the SCP
Foundation arrived on scene in the town
of mirni within the Saka Republic the
creature was on a rampage buildings were
collapsing as the winged Beast set the
nearby area Ablaze troops on the ground
even once they were able to get the
monster in Range found that their
Conventional Weapons were useless it
cost the lives of 17 mobile task force
operatives all emulated down to a cinder
before a chopper was able to neutralize
the creature with the threat destroyed
and the town administered with amnestics
and fed a convincing cover story you'd
think that was case closed on a job well
done but the foundation discovered
within the nearby mersey mine something
that would completely change everything
they thought they knew deep underground
was a sinkhole leading to a spatial
anomaly below consisting of the system
of caverns that the Mine Workers had
inadvertently stumbled upon that wasn't
all that the foundation was about to
discover down there and what they came
across would soon become one of their
darkest Secrets
scp-3667 it wasn't long before the
foundation began encountering other
usual creatures that seemingly appeared
in the vicinity of
scp-3667 however not all of them matched
the description of the original
bat-winged dog-headed pyromaniacal
visitor officially dubbed as instances
of
scp-3667-1 these creatures range from
the aforementioned monstrosity to a
whole host of other strange descriptions
one was an abnormally thin humanoid
creature with reddish brown skin and a
head that was too big for its ryrie body
it possessed an ordinary human level of
intelligence and even spoke modern
Russian matching the common local
dialect in conversation this being tried
to offer wealth or power in exchange for
a person's most valued possessions
however it seemed to possess no
anomalous abilities and would attempt to
renegotiate a new offer immediately
after a bargain was made then there were
the magistrates a group of 48 humanoids
with kyphotic curved spines all of them
were Furs and a variety of skulls from
animal moles such as Elks deer and moose
the foundation were still none the wiser
as to the true origin of all these
different subspecies of creatures they
were obviously emanating from the
sinkhole and the foundation had been
making use of ntf kai-5 codenamed
Solomon seals to eliminate instances of
scp-3667-1 that appeared From Below
surface-to-air missile systems were even
installed nearby should any more flying
creatures appear but further exploration
into the sinkhole and the caverns below
would only yield further questions and
even more strange entities the
four-person unit MTF Chi 5 Team 1 was
sent in to conduct preliminary
exploration into
scp-3667 to try and assess more
accurately the Threat Level posed by the
sinkhole and its bizarre residence
finding themselves in a large cave the
team followed the sounds of running
water to a wide stream the water a
yellowish gray in coloration they also
detected the sound of numerous Voices
All whispering in Russian but found it
too difficult to distinguish what they
were saying there were remains too of
some kind of structure that seemed to
indicate the existence of sentient life
within
scp-3667 there was a portion of a wall
even a hallway that led into a large
windowless circular room the floor of
this chamber featured an elaborate
Mosaic that seemed to have sustained
some damage but strangely it depicted
anomalous creatures including some that
looked like the first winged monster
that had appeared after splitting up
down various corridors two members of
Team One encountered a new entity from
within
scp-3667 this creature resembled a large
feline but had no eyes and was about 10
meters in height it referred to the MTF
operatives as Sinners and foolish
Mortals who should have stayed in their
cages despite being eyeless the creature
observed that the team did not possess
what it called The Mark of agriana and
remarks that they should not have been
there feeling threatened by the creature
ntf Kai 5 Team 1 was able to blow it up
with a grenade before being safely
retrieved by their fellow Foundation
Personnel exploration into
scp-3667 was then resumed by MTF Kai 5
teams 2 and 3 who were alarmed to hear
what sounded like a human scream coming
from somewhere within the caves while
they first assumed it was another 3667-1
creature someone suggested the
possibility that a civilian could have
stumbled onto the site of the mersey
mine before the foundation had arrived
and established a secure perimeter
around the sinkhole hearing the scream a
second time this time further away the
MTF agents decided to investigate just
in case an innocent person had been
dragged underground by one of the
creatures passing through a basin of the
same strange fluid that team one had
discovered the MTF teams could hear more
unsettling sounds coming from deep
within the caverns in particular a
repetitive scratching noise next they
discovered a large intricate wooden
structure a circle with one side that
appeared to be winched open inside they
could see rows of wooden spikes covered
in a dark liquid that everyone assumed
was blood hearing whimpers from their
supposed missing civilian the team's
Commander decided to call a retreat it
was then that the MTF realized there
were over 20 more wooden structures
nearby each was of a different shape and
size but all of them were covered in
rats that were staring at the foundation
operatives these various pieces of
wooden apparatuses seemed to resemble
torture devices and some of them had
bodies inside the MTF agents thought
they discovered the grisly fate of their
missing civilian little did they know
that things were far worse than they
first seemed the bodies and the torture
devices were still alive the foundation
soon realized there were upwards of 12
000 people within
scp-3667 and immediately began efforts
to rescue as many as they could luckily
they had established a field base on
sight in the mine close enough to the
sinkhole that led into
scp-3667 however the unfortunate reality
was that saving all these trapped human
beings was no small undertaking and
space at their nearby base site 574 was
limited only 150 of the people were able
to be recovered and were transported to
site 574. those that were having been
found trying to escape from
scp-3667 or being eaten by the various
nightmarish creatures below but what
quickly became apparent was that these
people those safely recovered from
scp-3667 and those still trapped within
weren't exactly ordinary when team one
had discovered the strange yellow gray
stream in
scp-3667 they'd collected a sample of
the fluid for analysis examining this
sample revealed an anomalous molecular
structure that would actively bond with
organic matter and this same
unidentified molecule was present in the
bloodstream of the human beings found
beneath the sinkhole it seemed to have
bestowed each one of them with an
anomalous ability for a limited form of
regeneration their bodies could
withstand far more damage than an
average non-anomalous human the
foundation even experimented with
introducing the anomalous molecule into
the blood of other test subjects but it
didn't have the same regenerative effect
it was assumed that the Regeneration was
linked directly to some other factor and
the molecule from the fluid only acted
as a catalyst as such every person
recovered from the caverns was given the
collective designation of
scp-3667-2 now various subspecies of
strange creatures and a group of people
whose bodies could regenerate both
living in a system of caverns beneath
mirni sakha Republic not to mention all
the wooden torture devices that were
being used on the
scp-3667-2s just what the hell was going
on here and what was it that made this
discovery one of the foundation's
darkest secrets well the answer to that
could be discovered in what they learned
next about the anomalous people they'd
recovered from the sinkhole as the
foundation continued its examination
their researchers at site 574 happened
upon a starting realization the
scp-3667-2 people were perfect physical
and genetic matches to former residents
of the nearby town of mirni in fact of
the over 12 000 total only 1 328 didn't
appear to correspond to any known person
from the area but then thousands of
others all had proof of their existence
that the foundation was able to recover
from the town's public records dates of
birth names former places of residence
family and next of kin along with dates
of death the
scp-3667-2 instances all claimed to have
spent their entire lives underground
beneath the sinkhole where they were
tortured endlessly by nightmarish
creatures their bodies could regenerate
the external damage they received
meaning the torture would go on for days
months or even years at a time when
sampling bodies buried in local
cemeteries the foundation discovered
that these were in fact copies of
deceased residents but not everyone who
had lived and died in mersey only those
whose families had lived there for at
least two generations and who while they
were alive were suspected of committing
a crime but never convicted there was
one other unifying Factor too during
their lives these residents all had some
affiliation with a particular religious
group known as the light of five Heavens
Russian Orthodox Church to put it simply
scp-3667 was hell following a number of
other incursions involving
scp-3667-1 creatures the foundation was
eventually able to open negotiations
with the entities in order to ensure the
continued stability of
scp-3667 the former director of site 574
nidai bokome was a point as the Director
of hell and placed in charge of
overseeing the anomaly under her watch
the foundation would supposedly be
relocating the displaced
scp-3667-2s to safe classified locations
where they could be reintegrated into
society however in an email from the
director of Hal she proposed a solution
to the foundation's dwindling number of
d-class personnel I am happy to announce
that something has come up that changes
that I'll be sending each of you a
shipment of new d-class come next week
it isn't as many as you had hoped for
but rest assured these ones will
withstand most anything you throw at
them now go check out scp-3000
anatashisha and scp-096's sad end for
more